le président des etats-unis a été reçu
avec les grands honneurs à londres après
le thé à buckingham palace dans notre
chance a eu droit à un dîner d'état aux
côtés de sa majesté la reine elizabeth
ii
les deux chefs d'état ont rappelé les
liens étroits qui unissent leurs deux
pays
sauf mais derrière le protocole et les
politesses d'usagé
certains membres du gouvernement
britanniques admettent que chang est une
figure qui divise c'est un président
controversé affirme le ministre
britannique des affaires étrangères
mais aussi un ami de la grande bretagne
certains ont été moins diplomate
comme le maire de londres ça des canes
qui ne voulait pas de dans notre homme
dans sa ville et au valium
un must en font des conneries hop c'est
pourtant devant l'us en avant l'ultime
inscription dans une entrevue au
magazine elle
il n'a pas caché son inimitié pour le
président américain
la dernière visite du président turc à
londres il ya un an avait provoqué des
manifestations monstres
le maire de londres rappelle au chef de
la maison blanche que son opposition au
libre choix des femmes à l'avortement
est un recul dans notre chambre n'a pas
tardé à insulter c'est cannes qui l'a
traité de perdre un de petite taille
la visite du président américain
survient au moment où les anglais
s'entre déchirent sur la façon de sortir
de l'europe
de nombreuses manifestations sont
prévues mardi à londres pour dénoncer sa
présence
c est dans notre chambre est en
angleterre pour célébrer le 75e
anniversaire du débarquement de
normandie en juin 1944 73000 américains
avaient alors traversé la manche en
bateau pour libérer l'europe des nazis
le président des états unis se rendra
également en france pour se souvenir du
sacrifice de ces soldats ici christian
latreille radio canada
couach une tenue